all right welcome everyone to the class
today and I prepared to show you one of
my very recent games I've been playing a
lot recently and played about five
tournaments in the last two months
and this one game I want to show you I
played at the World Open in the first
round against the 2,300 rated opponent
so and I liked the way how I played in
the middle game since this class is on
the middle game team so we'll talk about
how to play in the middle game the best
way to try to put the most pressure on
the opponent as possible yes I'm white
and my opponent plays east six and he's
trying to play nimzo-indian defense so
if I play Knight c3 then he will play
Bishop before and then we have a
nimzo-indian defense so I normally don't
like to allow Bishop before so I'd like
to go Knight f3 in these positions so
that way it's more difficult for him to
do anything as far as pinning me so but
now it is b6
g3
we should be seven
Bishop g2
we should be seven castle castle so this
is a very common position very common
position here to play in here a white
normally placed Knight c3 developing the
knight and black goes Knight e4 Bishop
d2 and and then black tries to play a5
but here I didn't want to go into a main
theory I was playing the young opponent
who I thought probably would know the
theory so I wanted to kind of play
something rare and I played the rook e1
move rook e1 the point of this movies to
actually it's a useful developing move
and I want to see now what he is going
to do next and now he Foursquare is
honor you know I'm trying to in the
names or Indian positions you always
want to try to control the e4 square if
you can now my opponent played D v e4
square I'm trying to control so it's
playing d5 to be able to control that
square if I go Knight c3 then he takes
my pawn I don't want to give up upon
okay
now what do you think you can try to do
here maybe better to take so that way we
eliminate his options of taking me now
he takes back with the pawn because if
it takes to the night I have efore
attacking the knight if he takes with
the bishop I go Knight c3 so he takes
back with the pawn Knight c3 and now he
plays Knight a6 the idea of this move is
to play c6 97 96 it's a typical it looks
a bit strange but it's a typical
maneuver for this position
the knife is well placed on c7 so I
activated my knight only 5 you played c6
Bishop f4 Knight c7 and now very
important move you're needed
yes question how to make this bishop
active now let's think about it
the light-square bishop needs to be more
active okay so that's what I would like
to do
activate the LightSquared bishop okay
because it's not as active at the moment
so what can we do to activate him yes
it's an interesting idea Bishop HT
certainly certainly be spatially is very
interesting but then he will play maybe
c5 or something
certainly okay but what else what else
do you have
yes that's the correct answer that's a
typical idea e for not only you opening
up the bishop you're also opening up the
rook okay that's the idea bishop and a
rock activating the pieces okay now when
I take for example now my bishop is
going to be attacking his pawn and it's
not protected by another pawn when the
pawn is protected by another part of
your Bishop can never take but if it's
protected by a minor piece if you have
enough pressure you can take that
actually so but also this helps you to
open up the rook file okay now he took
Knight takes e4
now my bishop is very active my logical
bishop my rook is also an open file now
he placed 96 attacking my bishop on f4
now my bishop is under attack what to do
what to do now the bishop is under
attack
but I would like to make sure my
light-square bishop diagonal is open
completely because right now that night
is on the way it's blocking me so what
can we do here to make sure that we open
that diagonal yes correct decision yes
Knight xf6 it exact with the bishop he
still wants to take the bishop here
Bishop to e3 very nice protecting the
pawn and our pressure on c6 pressure on
c6 okay
now what's the idea here for black it's
difficult because the pressure is huge
on c6 rook c1 is coming Queen a for this
comings a lot a lot of pressure okay so
now he goes if it was rook c8 for
example I go rook c1 and now again I
have more pressure on this a lot of
pressure okay so he takes
I take
and here actually I know it looks like
he made the wrong decision but actually
his decision was right here he had to
find the very best move here and if he
had done that he is only very slightly
slightly worse let me flip the board and
see if you can find the best move here
for block yeah
blacksmith what's the very best move
here
what is the very best move here for
black correct yes Queen c7 that's the
move actually he had to play because he
exchanged the Queens but the problem
when you exchange the Queens you have
nobody to protect your bishop
so you can never really play c5 and that
was a huge mistake on his part because
if he had played Queen c7 now the next
move is c5 and he will trade the light
square bishop and now here's an
excellent night only six so Queen c7 is
a very powerful move and like let's say
f4 then he goes here and rook d1 is
coming look D 894 it's comfortable
comfortable for black so if he plays
this well now I have to play this move I
must play this move otherwise I don't
have anything so what is the move here
for white now let's switch to still have
a small advantage to have that small
advantage I have to play this move to
have the small advantage I have to play
this move
yes c5
I have to do something so he doesn't
play see if I because if you play c5 you
don't have anything
yes possibility possibility what else
remember we're trying to talking about
stopping him from playing c5 yes yes I
mean I can make it that way that he
doesn't play c5 because he will lose it
he will lose a piece yeah very strong
correct again
Queen d6 everybody this is the move okay
exchanging the Queens very strong idea
because now he takes pawn takes and you
have a platform here as well and this
Bishop cannot move and now you have some
a4 a5 ideas putting some more pressure
here so this is really the best move
here
Queen d6 is a small advantage yeah it's
a small advantage but it's still an
advantage okay with a4 a5 we'll be
pressing ok we will be pressing here
okay all right so he took
I took 9 he went here proposing the
exchange of the rocks
not really I want to just continue
oppressing him and increasing the
pressure so how are we going to try to
put pressure yes you could go to v6 but
we did that in the other position
because it was a necessity but here it's
not because he's not writing to play c5
here we have a majority queenside
majority four and three why don't we try
to use that majority to our advantage
were eating of that how about we use the
majority Luke takes the rook takes the
eight why you just give up the file you
don't want to give up the file excellent
thinking yes f for threatening f5
correct why not now he plays g6
he says no I will not let you do that
G for yes we say we're going to push
anyway anyhow majority majority King
side majority okay now he takes takes
and he proposes the exchange of the
rooks and this is important moment it
here is you need to make a right
decision what decision you need to make
here as white
now the question is say oftentimes we
exchange pieces without even realizing
we should exchange oh we're not but
stronger player you become you realize
sometimes that not always you need to
exchange the rooks if the guy puts the
rook in front of you most of the time we
just stink it we should take that's just
a natural reaction and I've made that
mistake several times even being a
grandmaster I made a mistake it's not
it's tricky but I also learn from those
mistakes that not often you need to
exchange rules if you keep one pair of
the rooks on the board you have a lot of
resources with the rooks on the board
then without it in this position I have
advantage regardless so it doesn't
matter so that's fine but still you want
to play the very best move here and the
very best move is rook t6 I don't know
take taking f8 I'm not I'm not
completely sure if I want to exchange my
rooks remember absolutely no Siwon
there's no other options because that's
the best square because now we're
putting pressure on him a lot of
pressure well if you go rook c8 then I
go f5 I keep pressing because I have f5
so he cannot just play passively like
that okay so he gets decides to go 90
for trying to get active with 94 thread
is to go nighty to check okay now very
important move here needed don't rush
think a little bit getting a little bit
it's not so clear I had to spend a
couple of minutes to figure out which
one is the best because there are two
tempting possibilities here two good
ideas I have here but how to proceed the
question is how to proceed here
is that a guess or is that a is that a
guess or it's the really good thing
you're going to do that because he is
threatening 90 to check and my playing
looks before you actually stop that
threat because that just it's becoming
useless to check here King f2 was by he
gave too much my first reaction
okay so that's why I didn't want to play
King f2 but the book C 14 did is the
move that I played because now the shake
I just walking up and the night now
cannot do anything okay and the good
thing about this movie C can update C
Phi because his bishop is still
unprotected okay if it was 96 I have f5
attacking him anyway okay so he goes
here what to do okay we should take c6
check and now he quickly went to K 2 mu
K 1 thinking like he's winning my pawn
he three he is going to go to k2
actually a three that's what he was
thinking oh a three he can go okay - and
now this is hanging and if I protect he
can do some tactics you know check King
up King up okay it's not so clear yeah
it's not so clear here so I certainly
didn't want to allow him some contra
play and then he'll be back into the
game he's going to get back into the
game
so what's the move here King g7 we need
to have a follow-up f5 excellent work
yes because now if it takes you go check
and checkmate ok he cannot go here [ __ ]
page six
he takes now what do we do here
I know recapturing the pawn is very
tempting idea but here one second one
second let me finish but here is one of
those positions when you see a good move
you do what look for a better one
ok that's the example why you need to
remember that when you see a good move
you look for a better one and here where
is the better one see two hands ok yes
Bishop h6 Bravo
yes completely controlling the squares
and now threating a background check
mate you see that very difficult to do
anything the background checkmate is
coming on c8 the only thing you can try
to do here is f6 you write f6 now f6 now
what are we going to do now
the rook takes correct yes rook takes f6
of course because now after rook takes
f6 you threatening Brooke f8 mate and
it's simply unstoppable he cannot do
anything he cannot come up or do
anything and it's simply over all right
and he resigned here so that's the game
ok yeah I guess the only other thing
here it was a very nice natural oh I
want to talk about this f4 why am I
playing f4 why is this so effective here
because of what yes - go F I why am I
playing there because of which reason I
should do that yes yeah yeah nice nice
chain nice pawn chain yeah well I'm
playing there because of the simple
reason I have 4 pounds on that side of
the board and es3 so I'm trying to
increase the pressure got it
questions alright so that's the idea and
after that was again he tried to stop me
I say no and this decision was important
how many of you here would just trade
the rook here without thinking thinking
it's the it's you know it's like
especially in blitz anybody know nobody
I might have done it I might have done
it if this was a blitz game because you
know in blitz they put the rook
they take your rook they put the rook
and you say ok you would be worried
about his rook coming in
the problem with that is he's going to
get c5 in on time and then you're still
better there's no question about who is
better here it's me but I just try to
win it clean when they not clean we want
to clean victory now this will rook c4
it's very important okay take check
better now yeah right here yes don't
play a tree see you were suggesting that
earlier too slow you don't want that
okay you want f5 simply attacking okay
now Tooting check and mate if he takes
bishop here and mate on see it okay
alright very good
now I have a couple of positions I want
to set up for you to see if you can find
a solution okay okay middle gain n
middle game and endgame is very
important all right this is a pretty
difficult position but I will give you a
little bit of time to think and then
I'll help you okay
guide you to the right solution white to
play and win yes we're down a queen but
we're going to win a very nice study
here
usually we try to look for the first
thing we do we look for some possible
checks here right so let's try to see
what type of checks we have first we
find that out what checks we have okay
okay that's that's good the very first
thing you do is whenever you're trying
to solve puzzle study anything like this
start looking the checks first okay so
we have which checks you mentioned 95 or
92 okay that's already good good start
now we need to decide now which one is
the best which one will give you some
more chances you know to create Forks
look at look where his queen is his
queen is on b8 so if you go 92 your
night is going to be very far you can
create any fork threads right so that's
one of the ideas that you can do some
Forks maybe in this position 95 check
okay I'm going to help you a little bit
because it's difficult position
so check so let's try to do his ideas
he's got two moves here right
so King c3 or King a3 King a three
losses immediately do you see why check
and mate on a4 very good okay now we
eliminate King a3 now we come to the the
most difficult moment here King c3 and
you got to be careful because maybe he
will meet you which could be true if
you're not careful
that's another variant again we look at
the look at the checks first right this
should be - the problem is he goes King
D 3 and his sort of escapes now okay yes
very good
what did you say - say that again
exactly we need to do something to keep
him from escaping because he wants to
escape with the King again but that's
you're kind of pushing him yeah that's
you're kind of pushing him to the escape
now that's sort of you push them now
again - that's a little bit when you
your king is that's a good that's a big
hint bear okay so this D 3 square is if
the King gets there then it's we're not
going to be able to win okay so let's
think of something and there is a reason
why you played my day five okay there is
a reason why you played Knight a5 not 92
so you have this move here it's a it's a
very special move it's not a regular
move it's a very special move okay yes
rookie d4 okay rook d4 let's try to see
rook t4 the problem is I mentioned right
he is going to check you well probably
not made but you're not going to win now
it's going to give you a lot of checks
okay check tick
well right now we don't have a check
it's white no yeah it's not a check
right now the correct move no not
necessarily not necessarily it's it's a
very special move remember it's a very
special yes rook before okay she found
some excellent moves today so very good
rook p4 okay excellent move now
you connect things together and realize
why this move works first thing is now
remember I told you to night-night is
better on a5 because of some Forks if it
takes aha excellent that's one so if it
takes with a queen now now it's a skewer
check and the knight is controlling the
very important two squares so he has to
step away and yes I was going to say
that but that's something not for today
that's something I've kept I've kept
saying one day I will do like a video on
just this but it's always at the end of
the class so we don't have the time but
one day maybe somebody should remind me
just to do this exactly how to win I one
thing I can tell you I don't know if Ben
how many times you had this I've only
had once in the tournament this position
occur in a real tournament game I only
had once in 2009 Las Vegas tournament
but it's not very often you're going to
have this ok but it still will be useful
to night
yeah so we both had once you know and
we've been playing for you know very
long time so where's one more move here
we're not done yet here guys one more
move here what if you please clean g8
and it looks like now he kind of stops
your rugby three mate idea
what can you do now yeah yeah it's a
queen g1 it's a take it's still made
okay so it will be a draw very nice draw
but don't believe me immediately because
after Queen Jayde you still have the
check right do you see now what can you
do if you play the check
aha see for again he has King D 3 the C
4 check he goes huh
rugby 3 check now he will take if you
take his queen then this is a draw
because you cannot win this possession
with just a bishop
so but what you're going to do uh-huh
they should be two and again it's the
same idea his king cannot stay close to
the Queen he has to go away because now
Bishop takes this square and the knight
ecstasy for score so yes the move away
and you take the Queen and again we come
back to this position that Bishop and
Knight is a win but you only have 50
moves to do it okay so you only have 50
moves to do it
no 5 0 5 0 yeah yeah from here you feel
if you don't win in 50 moves then it's a
it's a draw
it's a 50 move draw rule ok one thing I
can tell you about this position is you
probably will be able to push this King
to one of the corners and the black
should go to the light square corner and
then from there you have to push a skin
to the dark the color of your Bishop so
dark score in this case and then you'll
be able to win and in one of the ideas
you're going to use there it's called W
maneuver with a knight your knight is
going to move like a W ok so I will just
show you that part he could try to stay
in the middle but he's not going to be
able to do it because you have two
pieces and they will take all the
squares so eventually you will get
this position okay and there might be
some other ways to do it but this is the
way I know how to do it so the night
controls the the light square because
your bishop is not effective in this
case so he will go here so okay we
should move and now this is how you
start pushing him to this corner okay so
now he cannot go back to b8 so and he
will go here and this is where that the
W maneuver is right here so your knight
will move like this d5 e 7f v g7 that's
why they call this a W maneuver so he
goes here check now you come here slowly
you will push them to h8 now it tries to
escape check now you continue with W and
in between you have to make sure you
make some waiting moves okay because you
want to make the knight move with a
check and now you continue kink on g8
again as soon as he tries to escape you
go check he goes here and now you can go
Knight f5 and now again always remember
the waiting move you make an item and
then a waiting move your waiting move
should be on this diagonal so it doesn't
escape and now mate until you see it aha
it should be free h6 okay
very good one more thing I want to show
you because otherwise thing is this may
happen and then you will mention that I
didn't tell you this because this is a
this is a little tricky moment when you
do the W if it was King see it and it's
it's kind of easy you just do this idea
that I showed you but if it goes King to
e8 then it's a little bit tricky but
still you'll be able to finish
of soaking these six King f7 it looks
like he's escaping here but now remember
this move Knight is seven again you
continue with your W move and control
this two important squares okay you know
you can because if he plays King f6 or
King g7 in both cases you play Bishop e3
now you control this squares see all the
squares now under control so he goes
back now you can go Bishop d4 now
controlling the f6 and g7 square now he
has to go back to the background now you
go here so he's trying now to escape
here and now Bishop here and now he's
back in that position and now you
continue with W right Knight f5 Bishop
c7 yeah check and the same idea okay do
you understand now how you can try it if
not easy I know but this is a this isn't
start okay this is that I've shoot a lot
of people who have videos on this how to
do it like very slow but just remember
the concept that I showed you first you
use your pieces to push his King to the
corner if he doesn't know that he needs
to go to the light Square then he will
get checkmated more quickly if he goes
let's say to the color of your bishop
but most likely he will go there and
then you just use this W idea W maneuver
to be able to mate him okay again it's
not it's not like you know very common
but I know some examples the biggest one
was when a world woman champion the
current at that time oh yeah she she
never studied it and she had it in a big
tournament and she was the world Wilma
champion at that time and she just never
started she didn't know how to do it
and she went around she went around for
a long time and then it was just really
embarrassing at the end that she did the
50-year move rule opponent normally like
normally at the very high level they
resign if you just kind of demonstrate
in the beginning that you know what
you're doing but she was not very sure
and her opponent you know didn't resign
and they playing on and on and she
didn't know that dabio maneuver how to
do it and eventually 50 move rules and
she had to give up a draw so that was
the big thing adda there might have been
some others some other examples but this
was a big one my example my example was
I was playing International Master from
Canada and okay I was better the entire
game that it was very technical
eventually I had a passed pawn normally
what happens you have a passed pawn you
and he has a rope you know you promote
he sacrifices and then you have this
that's actually how a lot of times I
think it happens this disposition and
then I start demonstrating but as soon
as I put him in the I did the W and it
was just couple of moves away he just
resigned because it was already clear
that I kind of knew what I was doing you
know but again I mean in 27 years of
playing this this happened only once so
some people some people maybe had more
but it's if it's very rare but it's it's
good to know position we just have two
kings
bishop and a knight yeah anywhere on the
board I would do it like the day we did
it with the dark square Bishop do it
with the light square bishop just it is
the same thing but do it with both the
concept is the same he will go to the
dark corner then you have to use it to
drive you to the other it's a good
exercise it's a it's a good exercise is
a good thing to know